avant son accident alors marius c'était
un élagueur on l'appelait le grand singe
parce qu'il était tout le temps haut des
arbres tout le temps en train de grimper
c'était un très très grand sportif qui
pesé 95 kilos de muscles et qui vivait
dans la nature avec ses potes toujours
en vadrouille dans des expéditions très
très sportif faisait beaucoup de sport
de natation de foot de boxe voilà
c'était les copains la fête le sport et
la nature
c'était ça marius
donc en fête marius donc il a eu à
un accident qui fait qui s'est fracturé
la colonne vertébrale très haute au
niveau de la vertèbre cervicale des
verts tels c5 et c6 donc en fait il est
tétraplégique complet ça c'est à dire
qu'il a perdu en fait l'usagé de ses
jambes et de ses bras on est en train de
récupérer un petit peu le haut du corps
alors ça c'est ce qu'on voit en
apparence en fait mais au delà de tout
ça il ya plein de deux problèmes
secondaires de peau de femme en ile et
je vais pas évoquer tout parce que
rentrer dans les détails mais ce qu'on
voit c'est une paralysie complète mais
appelant d'autres choses en fait c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça
marius maintenant c'est un grand point
d'interrogation parce que ben on ne sait
pas du tout en fait l'avenir vin c'est
tellement il a tellement perdu en fait
enfin toutes ses capacités
il est tellement obligé de recommencer
se reconstruire différemment
donc pour l'instant il met vraiment le
paquet pour récupérer et se reconstruire
physiquement et je pense qu'il fait un
grand chemin aussi psychologique pour
essayer de reconstruire une vie
intéressante qui lui plaisent
enfin marius maintenant il est vraiment
en mutation en train de devenir
quelqu'un d'autre est obligé